banks are still distributing money but
people here are nervous just last week
Greeks made 10 billion euros and
withdrawals many are putting their
savings under the proverbial mattress
but the big fish have already made their
move stashing their assets abroad that
stoked resentment and prompted harsh
accusations what they've done is not
okay they live here and they should
leave their money here the rich put
everything into foreign accounts and
that wipe sounds small savers de los
gatos they only have their own interests
at heart I judge that harshly heavily
this anyone who takes his money out the
country he is not a patriot he doesn't
love his country although the reform
plan still has many hurdles ahead of it
it's acceptance in Brussels brought a
sense of relief but that tsipras
government is still under intense
pressure to renegotiate the punishing
terms of the bailout it was a little
difficult an act quickly and effectively
to relieve the humanitarian crisis that
way people can see that things are
changing in their everyday lives but
making public services and
administration more effective will be
the hardest part the Phoenix the time if
greece wins time to implement the
planned reforms the hope is that people
will start putting their money back into
the bank